you
[Music]
I'll be talking about split learning but
that's the the brand name or the
technique name and the real title of
what it's about is basically a resource
efficient method for distributed deep
learning and the distributor comes in
the problem of not sharing the raw data
due to privacy issues and more things
like that you're gonna see that in the
next slides so this is the setting this
is a classic example taking a healthcare
kind of setting but this kind of
generalizes to financial or surveillance
or different techniques where sharing
your data is a problem but people would
like to build models that collaborate
and are in a distributed setting there's
been a lot of talks today in the morning
I've seen in the same room that's been
talking about distributed and things
like that so it's definitely it's
definitely good to see that the time is
here for working in areas like this so
so consider hospitals for example these
are local hospitals everyone has their
own data regardless of how much data any
single Hospital has it's still a small
data in comparison to what could be the
size of the data if you pull everything
together also every data that is
connected to the hospital the hospitals
are kind of biased by location and the
kind of data and kind of people they're
looking at so they could be a remote
this could in the worst case could be
remotely connected hospitals in remote
areas that are also resource constrained
that's like the hardest portion of it so
this is the setting so in some sense the
data is invisible it's there always but
you're not able to use it in a pool set
up so that's the classic distributed
learning situation so in the setting
these are the constraints we want to
keep in mind while coming up with
techniques or solutions be it from a
systems engineering perspective or be
from an algorithmic or like a learning
perspective in terms of the modeling one
needs to be very much aware of resource
efficiency in terms of computational
resources also memory memory efficiency
in terms of how much memory is being
used and especially in the distributed
setting the communication bandwidth
because one needs to be aware of the
fact that these edge devices may not be
hospitals they could be in a in a
parallel setting just like cell phones
or smart devices or like edge devices
and you cannot expect them to upload and
download gigabyte
of data and train ResNet hundreds or
ESMA to hundreds on them unless it's a
unless unless these processors are like
really really really well-designed and
like specific hardware to do things like
that so that's the setting it's a
distributed privacy and then incentives
is a gendered question that keeps coming
up especially when people keep talking
about blockchain but but I'm just
putting it there to understand the
constraints in the landscape ml
expertise because it's not only about
just in histograms and basic stats and
inference but also being able to do
training of learning models not just
prediction or inference but training of
learning models in this setting and
efficiency we talked about that so
you've seen the setting and the
constraints and this is what the problem
we work done is or like what you
developed in our group at MIT so this is
about training neural networks in the
setting under these constraints so this
we call this work split n n or split
learning it came out in 2017 in that
paper below and basically we guarantee
that there's no exchange of raw data
there's been a modified version of split
learning there's a constant flurry of
papers we're working in this area so
we'll get to the modified version where
there are additional advantages in terms
of how the leakage is reduced even if
there is no sharing of raw data there is
nevertheless going to be some
communication and then we look at this
modified version where the leakage is
contained even more so before I get into
the technique we have a diverse audience
so it's also worth looking at the
landscape at the higher picture for a
couple slides so the higher picture of
the landscape is there's a lot of active
work I need not say this in intelligent
computing artificial intelligence I know
AI is not here we call it artificial
intelligence what we're really doing is
intelligence amplification of the user
so I call it AI a but regardless there's
a ton of work going on in that space but
when we come to these specific sectors
like health care or like regulated
sectors like finance or surveillance and
security or even companies in any sector
that are not in a trusted setting so
these are competitors for example but
they want to do something together for
some specific goals so the big elephant
in the room is security
from a cyber perspective or like a
computer security perspective privacy
indeed of the individuals as well as at
the group level of the people that
you're looking at or targeting safety
they're literally this could mean
physical safety like you don't you do
not want to run a model that's a Pharma
model that's doing some dose-response
modeling it's trying to figure out what
dose to give during the clinical trials
this is like literally safety you don't
want to get ahead of yourself in trying
to get the drug out and and come up with
the dosage that is going to kill
somebody
of course we are glad that if there is
organizations that are regulating it's
awesome that we have we live in a world
with like legal implications but that's
something to be aware of there's another
parallel word or like buzzword in the
landscape people call it fairness
there's a lot of people working in terms
of fairness this comes to this brings in
act things like being unbiased with
respect to race color gender blah blah
blah
so regulations another quick landscape
I'm not a lawyer but but once you once
you search regulations in the privacy
space you see the area is moving very
fast in general technology moves much
faster than regulation and regulation
catches up but when you see regulation
is moving very fast you know technology
is like kind of outpacing very very
quickly there's been loss all over you
heard of a lot of these before a gdpr
HIPAA blah blah blah and then there's
also lost at the state level California
recently introduced its own privacy laws
with at the state level and not just the
federal level so regulations are moving
very quick so this like a nice indicator
of trends or what is happening on the
technology space so so so regulation is
there to catch the any breaches that
happened and those have been moving very
quickly as well there's been millions of
users that's been affected just in the
healthcare space there's a lot of big
companies and they're listed in there
and then there's also been millions or
maybe billions I don't know the total
number but this is like a huge amount of
money that is being lost as a result of
privacy implications and breaches as
well so there's a last one that I'd like
to show in terms of how some privacy
implications can also seem freaky so
this is from one of our popular news
news article that basically
shows if you look at the the bottom
picture it basically shows that little
school kids are being able to be
personally identified just from their
anonymous location trajectory
information so that's kind of scary
there's like a ton of pictures on that
news article that that made me get a
little freaked out about it but is the
reality the amount of data that's being
collected all over there's there's a
huge amount of inference that you can
make about the person at the individual
level and the one at the top shows
someone that collected for one
particular person this lady was tracked
in terms of her location trajectories
over 8,600 times with intervals of every
20 or 21 minutes 21 minutes so it tells
a whole lot of story about what's going
on so privacy insecurity is really
important it's a fast-moving field so
how do we train neural networks or do
machine learning in this kind of a setup
without breaching the the data sharing
aspect of things so these are all the
challenges and that I listed down the
reason I showed the setting the brief
definition of the problem and then the
landscape and then the challenges is
because we we call it spot probing in my
group at MIT where we basically list
down all the problems when we are trying
to find a good problem to work on and
then list down a lot of possible hammers
and also list on a possible constraints
just so that someone doesn't emotionally
get excited or attached to one single
problem before they start working in it
so this is the overall list of
challenges the one one so there's four
fronts to it one is about the kind of
data distributor it could be multimodal
one could be imagery data another entity
could have a time series data and so on
and the data is incomplete obviously
then there is the regulations aspect of
it and then there is the the ledgering
smart contracts maintenance is more
coming from from accountability and like
a blockchain style perspective and then
there's the resource constraints in
terms of what kind of algorithm you are
developing memory computation bandwidth
how fast algorithm is converging is
there synchronization issues between the
entities or these are synchronous or
synchronous and then also leakage in
terms of what is the real leakage that
is happening for any given algorithm
leakage in terms of the privacy of the
data sets so this is a little precursor
that kind of motivated the current work
and split learning
prior to that our group was were
one of the things that a group was
working on the deep learning front was a
architecture search there's been a few
talks in the morning that also talked
about this especially the one and
reinforcement learning this is and this
is one offer approaches that got really
popular as well and this is based on
reinforcement learning that tries to
find optimal architectures so that you
don't try a lot of combinations haywire
and you have some more structured way of
doing the architecture search while
training neural networks so this is okay
so this brings us to the final beginning
of where we are heading towards in terms
of the split learning so that's the
problem you're gonna train deep networks
know sharing sharing of raw images or
raw data in general there could be one
server multiple clients like a
hub-and-spoke model it could be like a
peer-to-peer model there's a multiple
configurations button it allows for
setting data friction issues we talked
about this now these are the whammer's
we've not talked about this so what are
the Hammers or problems are the possible
solution areas that are out there that
are popular one is anonymize I'll show
you in the next few slides why that is
not a good idea just leaving it at the
anonymous level just anonymizing or like
D identifying data is not at all good
enough I would consider that kind of
little more bully make a statement
saying if someone is anonymizing very
sensual sensitive data and then kind of
kind of distributing it the person is
either ignorant of what they're doing or
the person doesn't care because all the
information is out there and can totally
be de-identified and that might lead to
a humongous breach that ends up in the
newspaper so another approach is up for
scape so it's literally efficient so the
hammer that falls into this is
differential privacy by Cynthia dwarf
she won a Turing Award for her work so
this is a solid area of work that is
very active as well so people try to add
noise to the query or the or the
algorithm that you're computing and you
want to add noise in such a way that the
person who is more like an outlier
cannot be inferred from by doing these
operations on the data so basically if I
do this what is colloquially known as a
one plus one attack or like a plus one
attack
kind of a slang term that kind of refers
to an attack that differential privacy
really guards against and that attack is
basically say I'm an employee in a big
firm that has a millions of users of
data I can write a query that gives me
an output of maybe 10,000 users and that
is accounted for and that is audited for
and they might say I'm not trying to
query anything at the individual level
and then I might write another query
that will give out another ten thousand
or ten thousand one or like ten thousand
five records of data and then it's
audited for and I'm allowed to look at
it because the simple rule based
policies say I'm not looking at
individual data but then if I kind of
subtract these two I know I know
something very specific about a very
specific individual so you don't want to
do these neighboring data query attacks
and be able to figure out the privacy of
the person or do some sort of a join
with another data set that's publicly
available and break the privacy and then
there's encrypt this is one of the
strongest hammers available and by
encrypt I don't mean soul in encryption
from a shock and a perspective but this
is homomorphic encryption that's what
the the real term is and what they do is
you encrypt the data into ciphers which
you're all aware of and then there is a
homomorphic so like a parallel operation
that also you could do on these cipher
data so if I want to do additions of my
numbers of some private data I convert
the data into ciphers I send it to
whoever does the addition the addition
operation is a very weird operation a
parallel operation that is run on the
ciphers you get a cipher out the cipher
is sent back to the client
and then when he decrypt the data you
get the real answer or what the Edition
is supposed to be so it's like the
homomorphic encryption this is like
really really strong and to some extent
some support some sorts of homomorphic
encryption are also strong against
quantum computing kinds of attacks but
the biggest issue here is scalability
especially the addition problem
operation is okay but when you get to
doing like many many multiplication
operations it's not really scalable
enough it's still good enough to get
towards some sort of problems but to
train neural networks things like ResNet
50s which have like or 60 million
parameters or something it doesn't
really scale up at all they're not there
yet
that said the field is moving very quick
so you never know what's gonna happen in
there coming next five years so this is
a quick slide on why not of anonymity or
electricity identification of data and
then sharing it across is not a good
idea
so there's been some examples became
really popular about the giant attack
where they tick anonymized or
de-identified data sir and join that
some other publicly available data sir
and you really can can break down who
the who the person is although it's an
anonymous record so for example this
lady who's a who's been using AOL back
in the day was anonymized with her ID
number given there within AOL as a
company but there were people were able
to join her record and her behavior
about the public data and they were able
to figure out who she is and how she
looks like and where she lives in what
she does another data said that that
bore the brunt was the Netflix price
data which is very popular in the
machine learning and recommendation
system community as well people just
joined it with an IMDB data set that was
publicly available and like there is a
millions of people that were the
anonymized in terms of what they were
watching on Netflix it goes on to say
things like really complicated signals
and information like genomic information
that was anonymized and sent outside was
also d anonymized so it's like a really
bad idea to just share like an
anonymized or de-identified data and
think that it's good enough something
really bad could happen if specially if
it's a large data set from a large
company okay so this is how the space
falls under anonymize i'm not going to
talk about it anymore for obvious
reasons up for skate and then the split
and then that we introduced our split
learning we call it the smashed version
the one that there and then there's
encrypt on the other axis which is the
most powerful form of security that's
kind of available these days in terms of
homomorphic encryption but in terms of
what you could do with this because
everything is not scalable the scale is
you can go till inferring like
predictive modeling but you can infer or
do the prediction with your trained
model because you have a query to do the
prediction and there's a way to escape
the query with some noise but there's
also an issue that more and more
operations of using a physician that you
do more and more noise you need to add
to be able to preserve the privacy so at
some point you're keeping it private you
but you're beginning to use the utility
of the data so there's this dichotomy
between utility and how much noise
you're adding so just keeping things
private and not making data useless is
not a good
either and then comes smash I'll talk
about that because this whole slide is
about the smash approach and then
there's encrypt which I said goes up
till statistics but it's not even good
enough some there's been some recent
papers I should probably update this
that have done some amount of inference
with small data sets like handwritten
digit recognition M&S data and stuff
like that but there's four inference or
like for prediction if you already have
a train model there is no work at all
because there is no scalability for
homomorphic encryption for training a
neural network especially the ones that
are super large and not like one layer
or two layer style okay so our approach
is one of the earliest that does the
training the model there's also been
another approach that Google came up
with a few years back it didn't really
catch the eye when it came up because it
came out from Google ai because it was
definitely ahead of its time but now
it's got like thousands of citations
kind of running with it and ever and
talks about it in the distributed
learning space it's called federated
learning and we really love that
approach as well and we compare how we
do in terms of split learning and
federated what the pros and cons are as
well and stuff so we talked about this
federated learning differential privacy
stuff escaped the homomorphic encryption
is the encryption in this platooning so
this is farad learning there's a good
precursor to understand why we did split
learning because we really first focused
on ferret learning try to understand
what's going on so the federated
learning setup say you had a lot of edge
device or clients that are distributed
like in the bottom the cell phones and
tablets the DC and the desktops in there
there's a centralized server in the
federated learning setting the goal is
to learn a deep learning model in a
distributed sense but not share raw data
so raw data about these phones should
not go up or the same thing Roddy read
the server should not come down so what
faretta learning does is as follows
every entity trains their entire entire
neural network but every entity is
staying the same neural network the only
difference is the local data that is
being used by each entity is different
so so each cell phone just uses its own
local data to train its own neural
network so it's some sort of an ensemble
it's says what it thinks the weights are
supposed to be and it sends it back to
the server and then the server kind of
aggregates all these weights and then
you have an updated model during an
epoch so this is
during the training it's a slightly
updated model and then that updated
model is downloaded again by all the
clients and then they again train it
just using their local data so that's
the ferret learning approach as you see
the raw data is not leaving the clients
to the server there's a few issues I
mean this is a great approach but there
are some issues from an efficiency
perspective one thing if these networks
are like resonate fifties or hundreds
you're expecting the phone to do a lot
of huge computations and everyone's
training the entire network on their
device and there is there's a lot of
communication as well this Naturals
going to attack terabytes of
communication or like teraflops of
computation so it's not very efficient
from that perspective but it's a great
start it's still an active area you're a
big fan of federated learning there's
also being the classical approach that I
showed there have been different aspects
of federated learning that are trying to
there are kind of improving different
attributes about federate learning from
synchronization perspective from an
imbalance data perspective trying to
make it more efficient and so forth it's
a moving area so there's a survey that
we did in our group comparing federated
split and the other hammers that we
talked about in the previous slides so
there's been some papers that they're
just very learning obviously but there
have been papers that have been trying
to make federate and more private in
some sense or more secure in some sense
by combining these two hammers so we had
a list of different hammer zip so
there's a lot of papers that are trying
to combine these two like differential
private federated learning or
homomorphic encryption apply to federate
learning or secure multi-party
computation techniques applied to
federated learning the issue is once you
do that these hammers right from the
ones in yellow from differential privacy
till garbled circuits and oblivious
transfer are not very scalable
so you're basically restricting
federated to become not very scalable at
that point and already there is a lot of
communication overload and bandwidth
overload and things like that
federated just by itself is at least
able to achieve training but once you
combine these things you're not even
able to train the model because these
are only going in terms of scalability
up till inferring from inferring from a
model or from predicting from a model so
that's the space and split learning is a
similar situation although we have not
mind with these we try to come up with
our own hammer that kind of make makes
it even it makes the leakage in terms of
the communication that happens in split
learning much lower so I'd like to show
the result first and then talk about how
spec learning works so this is one of
the results comparing split learning to
Google's federated learning and this is
in terms of computation overload on the
clients you see this drastic difference
in terms of computation overload and how
quickly especially learning converges so
this is kind of super drastic and we see
this not although this flop plot is
about computation we see this in terms
of communication bandwidth split
learning is tremendously faster as well
when also in terms of convergence and
also like memory just not the
competition in terms of memory overload
of these clients that's our project page
and some papers and stuff we basically
couldn't compare this with federated
learning and also that what's known as
popularly known as large batch
stochastic gradient descent these were
pretty federated era super popular in
data center settings where you have this
huge data sets and then multiple data
centers or data silos that you're doing
distributing and that's like already
crushed by federated long ago so this is
more our numbers to the picture so split
n n which is our method in terms of so
this is on the vgg network is a large
deep learning network on the c 410
dataset it is a popular benchmark data
set in computer vision this basically we
ran an experiment with five hundred and
hundred clients distributed in the five
hundred client setting we use point O
three teraflops against five point eight
nine in the other so that's like super
drastic and same thing with the hundred
clients as well and then we also tried
on the C 400 is a much bigger data set
and a reson 850 which is even more
popular than vgg it's a very large deep
learning network and this is in terms of
communication bandwidth so 500 clients
we use 1.2 gig overall per client while
large-scale SGD use 14 gigs
and then federated was about 2.4 cake
the setting where federated was
reasonable was in the smaller number of
clients not in the cans but like say the
hundred clients where you see that the 3
GB is lesser than the 6 GB in terms of
communication bandwidth so switch
learning is especially suitable when you
have a large number of clients
especially if you had a million cell
phones it would get even more drastic
comparing versus federated so how does
split learning work and what is the idea
here so this is some classical ideas
there is we've added more and more
things but this is the most the crux of
the simple the simplest form of the idea
if you look at the top picture Alice and
Bob just two clients not 500 any more or
you could think of it like a client and
a server let's assume the labels are
known but the data is not allowed to be
shared so your feature service Alice and
Bob that are not supposed to be shared
Alice has some information maybe it
could be in a healthcare setting basic
electronic health record information Bob
could be like a major a like medical
major it could be an Imaging Center it
has all the MRIs and CT scans obviously
you cannot share them because of
regulations and things like that so what
we do in spirit learning is in terms of
the training we start train if we start
with random maze and we start forward
propagating because you have any puck at
the forward at a back prop so doing the
forward prop we keep forward propagating
until the split layer so we're literally
splitting the neural network and putting
them into different entities and
whatever comes out of the split layer in
terms of the forward prop just the
activations at the split layer are
communicated as against Confederated
where the entire network is shared by
everyone and everyone is training
everything and sharing everything every
single time so that's where it's like an
overkill in terms of efficiency and then
you have a full-forward probably get
some prediction with Bob and then you
start back propagating and then the
gradients are back propagated again at
the split layer just the gradients from
the green split layer go to the other
green spit layer you don't share the
gradients from the previous layers so
it's like a very minor projection of the
data and compared to what could be
otherwise shared if the whole thing is
known and then there's modifications and
many modifications will disappear
turning one of the popular ones is the
no label sharing so say I as Alice have
features and I also have the labels this
could be the diagnostic
what kind of a DC someone has or how
healthy someone is and then I have a lot
of input feature data so then is the
u-shaped thing where I forward propagate
for a while and then I send my
activations from my Spitler to Bob and
then Bob forward propagates for a while
so he's like the middle guy now he's
just transforming the data for me and
he's doing the number crunching and then
the learning but he doesn't know either
my labels for my raw data so there
everything's in-house at this point and
then you forward propagate and then the
fara propagate the the goes back and
then I forward propagate some more till
I reach my labels in analysis itself so
the labels are not leaving as well
so that completes an epoch and then the
same thing happens with the gradients in
the reverse direction and then the
weights are improved so that you're
learning better and better as you
complete all the epochs so now how does
it go 200 or finer clients we filed it
this is a paper we also filed some
patent and then fall our patent
applications after this so here you have
like many more Alice's and this is one
setting there's other settings too you
have a bob the same thing it's like a
relay in an athletics where everyone is
doing some computation and you're giving
something to the next guy and he runs
with it so this is some empirical
numbers of how huge these networks are
I'm sure a lot of you have already
looked at this or some sort of have some
estimator of these things so Alex near a
super popular deep learning network has
about 62 million parameters so you don't
want to upload and download that every
single time every few seconds
also if you see how they're distributed
you have these different convolutional
layers which are like image processing
related layers or computer vision layers
till end in max pooling after you're
done with the convolution fire on the
max blue layer there's fully connected
layers that's when it combinatorially
increases the weights increase a lot
more than known parameters if you see
the bigger numbers are in the last three
layers because wherever there is fully
connected so if you're thinking about a
centralized server which could be a huge
company or a hospital or a centralized
authority in a federal or like a state
government setting or a consortium of
academia or something of that sort but
the clients are like people like us and
individuals and cell phones or edge
devices or could be desktops as well but
these are clients in some sense that are
using the service
so if you see the amount of compute
is naturally also much lesser in terms
of what I need to learn in terms of my
weight so that means that even helps our
situation even better as a proportion of
what needs to be learned at the server
was this what is the load I'm putting on
the client because I'm I'm kind of
splitting and giving only very little
work to the clients and not not the big
work that needs to be done at the server
same picture goes on as you move to
different deep learning networks that
are popular like Alex net like ResNet 50
and so on so these are other versatile
configurations this is a paper we did a
20-19 the draft is out but this is going
to be out in ICL are in a workshop next
month so this is about different
configurations showing the plug-and-play
canned ability
depending on the situation or the
network topology you're dealing with so
the first one is more like a vertically
partition setting I have some variables
another guy has an other variables you
can expand it to many guys in terms of
the clients we split our do our
individual processing on using our own
local data no data sharing and then
whatever comes out of the activations at
the split layer we kind of merge the
merged a very popular operation in
cancer flora PI torch or in deep
learning in general and then we give the
merged version out to the server the the
third entity or whatever he could be the
300th entity and he runs away with that
again so there's another topology the
second one we've seen this the no label
sharing version so both labels and data
do not leave the client this is the
vanilla version and there's other
topologies as well we talked about in
this paper where split learning
naturally extends to okay so this is the
modified version especially during this
the most recent work that got accepted a
couple actually two days back
so I read these slides last night so
this is the top equation which is kind
of reducing the leakage in spirit
learning even further so that you have
some more guarantees that we have this
resource efficient distributed no data
sharing method but is there some sort of
a reconstruction attack in parallel to
what has happened with like the
anonymization attack in the early days
of anonymization or ID identification
for privacy so what can we say more
concretely about this so what we do here
there's this classic vanilla spread
learning setting you you've seen this
last few slides already so there's the
client there's the server we cut the
network that needs to be learned the
data doesn't get shared but then what we
did is we changed the last functions in
terms of how we are training the network
so the categorical cross-entropy is the
classical last function when you're
trying to do classification or or trying
to make classification with deep
learning networks so we didn't change
that because we want the utility of what
deep learning is supposed to do
so it's doing what it's doing but in the
early layers where the client side of
the processing is happening our goal is
to reduce the statistical dependency or
the information that is being sent
through the split activations whatever
is happening at the transferring of the
split layer whatever is coming out we
want to make it extremely uncorrelated
with the raw data so even if someone
interjects that be it like a crook
inside the company or it could be
someone who's doing some sort of a
cyberattack getting into the network
even if he interjects there he has
enough information to go forward but he
has no information to reconstruct the
raw data so so that's the overall idea
and then the way we do is we use
distance correlation or like a log
version of the distance correlation
which is a great measure of measuring
statistical dependence or independence
so we want to reduce the correlation the
distance correlation this is not the
classical Pearson correlation which is
only linear dependence this is a
distance correlation is a very good
measure of a dependence of random
variables in generals it would be very
non linearly related but still going to
reduce the correlation so that you
cannot go back to the raw data or you
cannot you can go back but not to a form
that you break the privacy of the raw
data so you want to learn split
activations of that sort and that is the
one that I transfer to the server so
there are two sides of this two sides of
the coin to this problem one is we want
to preserve this property where Z or our
activation functions Y are the labels
you're trying to predict X are your
input raw data we want to preserve this
property that as he should be useful in
terms of predicting Y the utility should
not be damaged that's the reason we put
in the categorical cross entropy in the
previous slide but also from a
statistical setting what we are trying
to do is you want to come up with a Z
which I give
of each a perch upon computation makes X
useless in terms of predicting Y which
is another way of saying X is
conditionally independent of Y given
that you know Z so if I if I'm like a if
I'm NASA or like a weatherman that has
already told you that it's gonna rain
100% if next one hour someone else
saying something else about rain is kind
of practically useless because they've
already given information to you so
that's all we want to make Z have all
the information that is needed in X to
be able to predict Y but the second
condition is the one-way property which
is we want to have that Z to be
independent of X itself that that weird
symbol is basically statistical
independence so that this is something
that is useful in predicting your labels
but it's something that is useless in
predicting your raw data back so that's
the one way property that you're looking
for we could look at so that we looked
at or the different measures of non
linear dependence or nonlinear
correlations we could look at this is a
very active area of work even now in a
lot of premier conferences in machine
learning there's some papers and some of
these almost every year so there's a lot
of measures basically so we don't need
to stick to linear correlations from
high school era of Pearson correlation
and things like that so the one we chose
a distance correlation where the thing
is we did some more survey to understand
this landscape a little more before just
jumping with distance correlation and we
realized mathematically most of these
correlation measures especially from
constraint covariance till the kernel
target alignment are very similar to
each other there's a lot of
correspondence as mathematically they're
doing something at a different in a
different way in terms of what they're
doing but what is it that they're
preserving is kind of very similar okay
so why is it called distance correlation
first the pretty picture so there could
be a lot of dependencies between data
your data could be multivariate this is
just a bivariate example with two
variables you can have a linear
correlation to something Pearson's
correlation can already detect very well
you can have a nonlinear dependency so
it's not like noisy data it's very
there's there's a lot of signal in the
second picture and be in the top right
but that's something Pearson's
correlation from a high school
standpoint would not be able to detect
because of the non-linearity that you're
looking at so distance correlation and
other measures that I showed in the
previous slide the more recent ones they
are able to detect that similarly I can
be more examples of that sort and it's
called distance correlation because in
some sense I'm computing Euclidean
distances of my raw data and my labels
and I'm doing some sort of a inner
product or like a correlation in between
those Center distance matrices there's a
lot of Cornell method or like free SVM
error kind of mad that could be done in
understanding why and what this is
implying but but anyway since we're
using distances and computing
correlations and I'm looking at how
similar my feature data is and how
similar my labels are and how they're
going to well together that's a very
intuitive sense of what distance
correlation is doing and that's hence
the name distance correlation so this is
the paper in 2007 and and also
statistics that introduced the distance
correlation the ones in blue from a
continuous standpoint what distance
correlation is measuring is if I have
two random variables x and y so X could
be mined but data of I could be my
labels of whether someone has cancer or
not or a tumor or not and then you want
to measure how dependent this data is
with respect to those labels and what
it's trying to measure is it's trying to
look at the joint probability and the
definition of statistical independence
from my statistician days is can you
split can you factorize a joint random
variable into product of its marginals
so it's kind of measuring that in that
integral how far can I factorize a joint
random variable into a product of its
marginal so it's like a measure to
measure of independence or dependence
and then the computation you saw in the
previous slide with the distance is an
inner products it's like a sample
statistic to estimate this this quantity
so it's it's a very holistic measure of
dependence and it's also very highly
unbiased estimator so in a paper in 2018
I before I came to MIT I did this work
where I formulated that the distance
correlation that you're computing in the
sample statistic the same formula has
some strong relations to graph theory so
I can look at the neighborhood structure
of how my feature data looks like and
how the clustering relationships are and
so forth I can look at the neighborhood
relationships of my label data and then
essentially the numerator term
the distance co-variants the
unnormalized term is basically measuring
what is being what is used classically
in embedding or like manifold learning
techniques or like teeth new kind of
techniques that is also used in
deepening companies these days it's kind
of measuring how much the neighborhood
information in my label data is able to
explain the neighborhood information in
my input data so there's this classic
connections to clustering and classical
problems like manifold learning that the
distance correlation is measuring
although we are not maximizing in our
paper we are minimizing the correlation
so that you cannot reconstruct the raw
data by doing any interjection of any
communication happening during split
learning so this is a real-life example
that we ran on a large data set early
the Ross largest relative on a
reasonably public large data set
available also on kaggle this is like a
colorectal histology image data set in
their different classes or different
kinds of healthy' or like different
kinds of tumors that needs to be
identified and we ran this through split
learning and this is how the leakage in
terms of distance correlation was
reduced so the the drastic numbers are
as follows if you did traditional CNN's
traditional deep learning without any
leakage reduction the the the
activations that you're you're going to
use or communicate are correlated from a
zero to one scale where one is being
very correlated to as correlated as 0.96
so yeah so you you might think you're
giving something that is d anonymized
and transform from the raw data but
there's almost all information in there
for you to be able to run another deep
Learning Network back and reconstruct
the raw data so in our in our setting we
reduced it to 0.1 9 and the M&S dataset
but M nest is like a classical tie small
data set and this this is the one in the
colorectal way it was reduced from 0.92
to 0.33 after a thermic box but then we
also want to look at okay we reduce the
likud we're gonna look at is it working
or not is the utility existing so we
were able to achieve the same validation
accuracy without and with split learning
or no peak split learning so these are
different weights so what is what is
giving away so there's no magical
solution there is no free lunch and if
there is free lunch there's something
wrong with it
unless it's family or something very
trusts about but in an untrusted world
there's no free lunch
so so what is giving away is basically
the number of epochs required is
slightly higher sometimes sometimes it's
much higher as well so as I keep
increasing the effect of reducing the
leakage through my distance correlation
loss the number of epochs it takes to
converges to reach the same level of
accuracy somewhat higher but but is it
worth it it's definitely worth it
because you don't want to have a breach
where you have like 80 million record in
dollars or something slapped on that
companies face because there are some
leakage from some model that it's being
here so this is a this is at and we are
also reaching the the capability of
being able to train neural networks in a
private sense something which is not
much heard of so this is some basic
reconstruction experiments in terms of
seeing if the theory is also showing
value in empirical practice but we're
doing even more work in here this is the
beginning of these reconstruction
attacks we've been applying so we took
the classical M&S data set what you see
in the bottom are so this is an
autoencoder it's no longer a
convolutional neural network it's takes
data in it tries to reconstruct the data
back in a typical sense it tries to
learn some compressed representation in
the middle layer which tries to
reconstruct the original data back so
when we applied our split learning the
distance correlation reduction leakage
reduction loss the attend coded kind of
miserably failed it was not able to
reconstruct what was what well that has
all the information that is still useful
to classify the digits in the forward
layers to up to 99 or 98 where the when
the standard accuracy is so you have
some sort of a representation which can
go forward but it sends it of a one-way
representation you cannot share the raw
data back so this is useful in the
street learning setting so we're
reaching almost towards the end of our
slides so this some theoretical word we
can talk offline about this in terms of
how we prove one way nature of this of
so this on proofs and stuff but anyone
that's interested in theory we can show
how we guarantee this one-way nature of
the distance correlation reducing loss
this is another ad ad or some sort of a
call-out and some sort of a special
invite and a welcome for cvpr 2019 in
long beach again in california we
we're giving a half-day tutorial that
was accepted on this topic distributed
private machine learning for computer
vision we cover federated learning split
learning and beyond this more hands-on
more more in depth because we're
spending a half day on this and the
first two authors are from Google that
find it Federer to learn start from our
group Hasan tucupi is kind of a
proponent of privacy related work in
Texas so that's the project page a lot
of acknowledgments and especially thanks
to a lot of people and collaborators and
friends it's fascinating talk I was
wondering if I want to use like a big
neural network like vgg 16 for example
and apply split and learning to it what
kind of heuristics to have to apply to
get the optimal splits essentially
between different clients how do I go
about doing that optimal in terms of
where to split and what topology to use
exactly so we thought about that's a
good question by the way there's
something called information bottleneck
there's also a very publicized
journalistic article in the quanta
magazine about it which is the phenomena
of how the information flows in a neural
network so in the initial layers there
is more information about the raw data
as you go towards the end there's more
information about what you're trying to
predict but the problem is the standard
neural networks are not separating or
dichotomizing this into saying making it
one way basically just preserving
forward information going back so
traditional neural network is just
splitting so split towards the end is
better but the problem is you're giving
away in terms of the computations
because there are more parameters
towards the end or layers but no peak
splitting is also part of Spadina it
gets the best of both worlds trying to
use the efficiency and the key classical
skeleton of what split learning is but
also it reduces this loss so if you're
trying to reduce the loss you can have
your layers split even at that second or
third layer which means the client need
to compute very little
[Music]